guys just call it like you know like
darkness well that would have worked
right it would have been fitting oh man
speaking of darkness we're going over
the team darkness here with mugs TV five
fun in front of them that kill fill up
that's never mind skilled down for you
sir
Oh Oh very good that was a nice one
that's what I do you know why they pay
me moderate dollars they keep coming oh
they got the hit he's going for that
upper torso shot big polite land it he
was on for a head shot that's what you
were hoping for the duck or something
great mugs only goes for the face it's
just how he operates would you say it
would be only for the mug only for the
mug oh yeah like a sir you should become
a commentator a new man reached I cannot
be as good as you guys do this more
often
I love it waiting around here mullet
we're planning a no man's land here a
lot of the gameplay that we've seen has
been it's no man's land action but we
haven't seen some really good trench it
you know
I think it's typical of the conquest
game over into the constant movement
there blow yeah so if you if you leave
your own Treach you go into dome as that
taken objective the chances are the
enemy teams play now behind you were
taking one of the observers oh and I
found my biggest success is usually when
I'm trying to oh one or two points I
can't even with you right now mugs look
I know you guys are trying to like talk
about how great I was having trying to
be strategic about this this is how you
do it this is what you have the ribbons
left and right you just go through any
shred period man let's take D I hope he
can take this you're just renamed
himself a blender white Oh lad that shot
he was going show and suppressed by that
fly already landed it straight in the
chest sky man he is just absolutely
incredible because with the chapel here
the ruins
looking for the next stop whoa headshot
is that a head shot I don't know here we
go fell it was close you want dead mojo
good I can't believe the shots he's
getting he's just getting assistant
there counting his kills cuz they're
like why would push why not well he's on
his finishing it off there we go
I think it was one more left Tomita
always switch kits switched out to the
support kit he was probably running out
of ammo there they get good players I
just do that I haven't I haven't run out
of ammo before yeah well that's like uh
happens me whole time whole days oh
there it is there it is
that was a trench Raider kill what we
feel like we have a new generation of
history buffs who a merged because of
battlefield one like people who are
genuinely into the history of World War
one yeah because it is it's the Great
War but there is so there's so many
stories to tell and things that people
just don't really know about which is
makes it very you know the guessing
encapsulating right it makes you want to
learn more but you know we're gonna
check out the sniper gameplay personally
man doom 49 don't let us down buddy get
those shots yeah he was able to get an
enemy hit they're giving him eating
points he's just gonna continue to march
down here to 40 getting ready up for the
Danzig train branch I'm looking for him
to take off some faces here it'll be
pretty tough if you'd be able to do so
and they have four points right now so
they are marching down the battlefield
no pun intended
I'm sorry it's actually very interesting
because if you look at it looking all
that was a nice shot there that was
lovely if you look at the points as I oh
it's done on the street oh no if you
would have gone that shop through the
trees I would have just put this heads
are down walk away the motor is the
Westie I think to your point I think
that because this is a balanced map it's
in very symmetrical I think that this is
that's what makes this really easy
have those yeah cuz I've been looking at
it but the structure of it almost with
the trench sides being very similar yeah
you've almost got that he's gonna meet
Brett effect there we go there we go
nice I see that title guy
she's taking a hitch on it oh all it
takes a just literally all you have to
do is breathe on him and bugs will fall
here so he's got to be very careful
there is a pathogen good night good shot
there bugs looking to do it again
there you go even need a gun all you
have to do is take the bullets and then
throw it at mugs and then bugs would
have would have died this on that alone